Transcriber: Emre OKUR
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Merhaba, size öncelikle çok kısa bir
hikaye anlatarak başlamak istiyorum.
Lilith’in hikayesi.
Bir efsaneye göre Lilith, Adem’le birlikte
eşit şartlarda yaratılan bir kadın.
Havva’dan önce yaratılan bir kadın.
Adem’le tamamen
eşit şartlarda yaratılıyor.
Fakat Adem’le cennette yaşarken
Adem her şeyi ona yaptırmak istiyor.
Yani onun üzerinde bir hüküm kurmak
istiyor ve Lilith ona karşı gelerek
cenneti terk edip cehenneme gidiyor.
Tamamen kendi özgürlüğü
ve bağımsızlığı için.
Ve Adem’in, Tanrı’nın ve meleklerin
yalvarmalarına rağmen,
asla bir daha cennete geri dönmüyor.
Daha sonra Tanrı, Adem’e
o kadar üzülüyor ki
Havva’yı, Tanrı,
Adem’in omurgasından yaratıyor.
Ve daha sonra aslında
hikaye başlıyor.
Benim hikayemde
Havva’dan değil,
Lilith’den Sofya’ya kadar
uzanan bir hikaye.
Kusura bakmayın çok heyecanlıyım.
Çünkü şu an bir hayalim gerçekleşiyor.
Teşekkür ederim.
Ben Elif Eda Güneş.
Yozgat’ın küçük bir köyünde
doğdum, büyüdüm.
Küçükken yıldızlara bakıp
hep hayaller kurardım.
Ve dünyayı değiştirme ve devrim
hayaliyle büyüdüm aslında.
Babam devrimcidir.
Ne kadar istemese de
beni oradan uzak tutmak istese de
ben yine onun yolundan gitmek istedim.
Ama benim hayallerim biraz daha farklıydı.
Benim anladığım devrim anlayışı
onunkinden çok daha farklıydı.
Bu yüzden hayallerimi hep
yıldızlara bakarak kurardım ve...
Nasıl yapabileceğimi düşünürdüm sürekli.
Nasıl kitlelere hitap edebilirim,
nasıl değişim yaratabilirim,
nasıl istediğim devrimi
var edebilirim diye düşünürdüm.
İlk projemi anlatmak istiyorum size.
İlk projem benim...
8 yaşındayken, ikinci sınıfa geçmiştim.
Köyde gördüğüm, çevremde gördüğüm
cinsiyet eşitsizliklerine karşı
bir projeydi aslında ve ben o zamanlar
bunu farkında olarak yapmamıştım.
Yani bunun farkında değildim.
Dünyadaki bu eşitsizliğin farkında
olarak değildim.
Yeni okuma yazma öğrenmiştim ve köydeki
kadınlar okuma yazma aslında bilmiyordu.
Ve bu yüzden haklarını da
savunamıyorlardı.
Ben buna karşı, “Eğer onlara
okumayı ve yazmayı öğretirsem,
belki haklarını savunabilirler
ve onlara karşılaştıkları
olumsuz durumlarda mücadele edebilirler.”
diye düşünerek yapmıştım.
Köyde isteyen kadınlara okuma yazma
öğrenmiştim 8 yaşındayken.
Daha sonra, “Bunu sporla yapabilirim.”
deyip futbol oynamaya başladım.
“Tiyatroyla yapabilirim ve sahnede bir
sürü insana hitap ederek...
Değişim yaratabilirim, bir değişimin
parçası olabilirim.” diyerek...
Tiyatroya başladım.
Ama hâlâ içimden bir ses bunun,
bunlarla var olmayacağını
ve kendimi bulamadığımı söylüyordu.
Tiyatro yaptığım dönemde Kayseri’ye
taşınmıştık ve bana bir telefon alındı.
Ben o telefonla bütün yazabildiğim
Türk bilim insanlarına mesaj attım.
Ben değişim yapmak istiyordum.
Bir köyde doğdum, büyüdüm.
Sizce bunu yapabilir miyim?
Umut Hoca'dan, Umut Yıldız NASA'dan.
Hâlâ da hocamdır ve çok gurur
duyuyorum bununla.
Umut hocayla yaptığımız
birkaç dakikalık konuşma,
benim için çok büyük şeyler yarattı .
Beni bir ekiple tanıştırdı ve
orada ben yazılım öğrendim.
Daha doğrusu yazılım denen şeyi öğrendim.
Benim yazılım hikayem,
kağıt kalem aslında şöyle.
O dönem köyde olmam gerekiyordu.
İnternet yok, bilgisayarım yok.
Nasıl yapabilirim?
Python dilini biliyorum sadece,
ama Python’ın ismini biliyorum.
Gittim PDF çıkarttırdım ve
Python diline dair,
işte örnek kodlar...
Algoritması, hepsini çıkartıp
başka bir kağıda aktararak
aslında ilk aşamayı
öğrenmeye başladım.
Lise ikiye geçtiğimde üniversiteye gittim
ve üniversitede dedim ki
“Ben bunu profesyonel olarak
yapmak istiyorum.
Ben gelecekte yazılımcı olmak istiyorum.
Bana öğretir misiniz?”
Orada da çok iyi insanlarla tanıştım
ve lise ikideyken
üniversitede ders almaya başladım.
Python algoritma dersleri aldım.
Bir yandan Erciyes Teknopark’ta
proje geliştirmeye başladım.
Bunları yaparken hâlâ kendimi
bulabilmiş değildim.
Yani, evet... Para kazanmaya
başlamıştım.
14 yaşımda, tek başıma yaşayabiliyordum.
Para kazana biliyordum,
ama istediğim hayal bu değildi.
Benim hayalim dünyayı değiştirmekti.
Şu an, ilk başlarda bana da çok komik
geliyordu, size de gelebilir.
Hiç yargılamam.
Sonra ne yapabilirim diye düşündüm
ve Kelebek Etkisi adında
bir projeye başladım.
Bu projeyle iki yıl boyunca
köy okullarını, onkoloji servislerini,
otizmli çocukların olduğu okulları gezdim
ve onlara, “Bilim nedir, teknoloji nedir
ve ilerde hangi meslekler olabilirler.”
bunları anlatmaya başladım.
Hatta bununla ilgili çok duygulandım,
belki ağlayabilirim.
Kusura bakmayın, bir hikayem var.
Onkoloji servisinde Elif adında
bir hastanın yanına her gün gidiyordum.
Ailesi yanında olamıyordu.
Ben de ona ablalık yapmaya
çalışıyordum kendimce.
Dizimde uyutuyordum.
Birlikte resim yapıyorduk.
Bilimi, teknolojiyi anlatmaya çalışıyordum
kendimce ki bir umudu olsun,
hayata tutunsun, yaşamaya
devam etsin diye.
Pandemi döneminde gidemedim.
Onunla her gün bir de tuz yiyordum.
Bilimsel bir açıklamasını şu an yapamam,
ama doktorlar tuz yedirmeye çalışıyordu.
Çünkü serum yoluyla alması onun daha çok
hastanede kalmasını sağlıyormuş.
Her gün gidip onunla tuz yiyordum,
ama çok fazla tuz.
Pandemi başladıktan 5 ay sonra
benim bilmediğim bir numara aradı.
Elif’ti. İyileştiğini söylemek için
aramıştı beni.
O zaman tam da
pes hissettiğim bir dönemdi.
“Pandemi, hiçbir yere gidemiyorum.
Ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
Hiçbir şeye dokunamıyorum.
Hiçbir insana dokunamıyorum.”
dediğim bir dönemde,
Elif’in araması beni tekrardan
hayata bağladı diyebilirim.
Daha sonra daha çok çalışmaya başladım.
Daha çok yazılımla uğraşmaya başladım.
Fark ettim ki yapay zeka yazılım
aslında bir sürü insanın
hayatına dokunabileceğim bir şeydi.
Teknoloji özellikle bir sürü insanın
Önemli olan onu doğru yönetebilmekti.
İstanbul’a gelmeye karar verdim çünkü
edindiğim iş ağları İstanbul’daydı.
Yapabileceğim işler buradaydı
ve liseyi bitirdikten sonra
Vodafone’dan teklif gelmişti bana.
O yüzden ben de İstanbul’a taşındım ve
Vodafone’da çalışmaya başladım.
Bir yıl inanılmaz bir
deneyimdi benim için.
Orada takım koçu oldum.
Mobil Uygulama Geliştirme
departmanındaydım.
Bir sürü şey öğrendim.
Daha sonra da TÜBİTAK'a geçtim.
TÜBİTAK’a geçtikten sonra
şeyi fark ettim.
“Ben kendi işimi yapmak istiyorum.
Ben yönetim tarafında olmak istiyorum.
ve bunu nasıl yapabilirim.” dedim,
araştırmaya başladım.
Sonra genç yenilikçi bir şirkette
yönetici olarak çalışmaya başladım.
Bu şirketin amacı tamamen inovasyon.
Bizim... Şirketlere zorlu görevlerle
ve yazılım yarışmalarıyla aslında
dışarıdan proje geliştirebilecek ve hayata
geçirebilecek insanları sağlıyorduk.
Bu beni inanılmaz motive ediyordu.
Şu an Link adında genç yenilikçi
bir şirkette çalışıyorum.
Burada da içerik yöneticisi
olarak çalışıyorum.
Aslında kısaca hikayem böyle.
Yani gerçekten Lilith’den...
O mücadeleden...
Mücadele için vazgeçtiğim şeylerden...
Başlayıp bugüne kadar geliyor.
İyi ki vazgeçmişim diyorum.
Çünkü bu yolda ailemden,
arkadaşlarımdan... Her şeyden vazgeçtim
ve hiç de pişman olmadım.
Şimdi bir soru gelmişti bize.
Teknoloji mi kadını var etti,
kadın mı teknolojiyi?
Bunu ilk duyduğumda çok sorguladım.
Neden böyle bir şey düşünülmüş olabilir?
Yani, “İlk programcı bir kadınken
veya sokağa çıktığımızda
kadının eserlerini görüyorken
sanatta, toplumda, bilimde, teknolojide
her yerde biz varken
nasıl böyle bir soru
gelebilir?” diye düşündüm.
Ama ne yazık ki böyleydi.
Benim gittiğim okullarda gördüğüm şeyler,
çevremde yaşadığım şeyler,
insanların yaşadığı şeyler böyleydi.
Ama ben bu soruya net bir
şekilde cevap veriyorum.
Biz kadınlar her şeyi yaratmaya devam
ediyoruz ve devam edeceğiz.
Birazdan arkamda bir fotoğraf olacak.
Bu fotoğraftaki kadınlar
benim hayatıma dokunan kadınlar,
benim hayatımda her
zaman yeri olan kadınlar.
Biri de hatta burada,
her zaman yanımda oldu.
Şu anda da bir proje üzerine çalışıyorum.
Tamamen kadınlar üzerine yine.
Kadınların sağlıkları ile ilgili.
Kadınların sağlığa dair
öğrenebileceği her şeyi
içeren bir uygulama üzerine çalışıyorum.
Bundan sonra da çalışmaya devam edeceğim.
Var olmaya, toplumda hepimizi var etmeye
ve burada diğer kadınların adına
var olmaya devam edeceğim.
Fotoğrafı alabilir miyim?
Kusura bakmayın bekletiyorum.
Mantar tutan annem.
Hayattaki en büyük
gururlarımdan birisidir.
Çünkü benim bu sahnede var olmamı sağlayan
şeylerden biri annemin çalışması.
Üretici bir kadındır.
Diğer kadınlar gerçekten hayatımda
çok önemli yeri olan kadınlar.
Şu an çalıştığım kadın 27 yaşında.
Merve Yorgancılar ve amacı, tek amacı
şu an mavi yakanın dijitalleşmesi.
Şu an biz mavi yakanın dijitalleşmesine
yönelik çalışmalar yapıyoruz.
Bir yandan ben mavi yakanın
dijitalleşmesi ile ilgili
Marmara Üniversitesiyle birlikte
bir makale yazıyorum
ve bu yaşta...
Benim yaşımdaki kadınlarla
birlikte çalışıyor olmak
gerçekten bana çok gurur veriyor.
Buradan teşekkür etmek istediğim
kişiler var.
Üreten, teknolojide var olan, sanatta var
olan, yaşamın her yerinde olan sizlere,
dünyadaki bütün kadınlara
teşekkür ediyorum.
Var olun, var olmaya devam edeceğiz.
Ayrıca Cumhuriyet’in 100′üncü yılında da
bu sahnede var olmamı sağlayan
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk’e
çok teşekkür ediyorum.